>>> THE ATLANTA BRAVES WIDENED
THEIR LEAD IN THE WORLD SERI
AGAINST THE HOUSN ASTROS NOW
AHEAD 3-1.
>> AMONG THE THOUSANDS TAKING IN
THE GAME WAS FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
HE'S NOW DRAWING SCRUTINY THIS
MORNING FROM SOME FOR TAKING
PART IN THE CONTROVERSIAL
TOMAHAWK CHOP.
HE WAS ONE OF MANY IN THE CROWD
TO DO IT.
IT'S BEEN A CHANT AND GESTURE
USED AT BRAVES' GAMES FOR ABOUT
THREE DECADES NOW, BUT IT'S BEEN
CRITICIZED BY NATIVE AMERICAN
ADVOCACY GROUPS AS MOCKING
NATIVE CULTURE.
THEY ARGUE THAT CHOP AND THE
TEAM'S NAME IS RACIST, REDUCING
NATIVE AMERICAN HISTORY TO
CARICATURE.
OTHERS ARGUE THAT THE CHANT IS
ACTUALLY A TRIBUTE AND WE SHOULD
NOTE THAT SIMILAR CHANTS ARE
PERFORMED BY OTHER SPORTS TEAMS
LIKE THE FLORIDA STATE SEMINOLES
WITH SUPPORT FROM SOME NATIVE
GROUPS.
NEVERTHELESS, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, NO STRANGER TO THIS
KIND OF CONTROVERSY.
THIS ONLY THE LATEST EPISODE IN
A CAREER THAT'S BEEN MARKED BY
CULTURALLY INSENSITIVE AND OFTEN
DOWNRIGHT RACIST STATEMENTS.
>> IN THE MEANTIME CNN'S DONI
OWE SULLIVAN WENT TO THE
BALLPARK AHEAD OF THE GAME AND
SPOKE TO GEORGIANS ABOUT HOW
THEY FEEL ABOUT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT SHOWING UP.
>> BASEBALL FANS SHOWING UP HERE
AT THE WORLD SERIES IN ATLANTA
TONIGHT HAVING MIXED FEELINGS
ABOUT THE FORMER PRESIDENT
SHOWING UP TO THE GAME.
HAVE A LISTEN.
HOW DO YOU THINK TRUMP WILL BE
RECEIVED HERE?
>> I HATE TO SAY IT.
>> HATE TO SAY IT.
>> WE ARE FANS.
>> YES.
WE LIKE HIS POLICIES.
WE DON'T LIKE HIS ATTITUDE
SOMETIMES, BUT WE LIKE HIS
POLICIES.
>> YOU THINK HE WILL GET SOME
MORE CHEERS THAN BOOS MAYBE
TONIGHT?
>> MORE CHEERS THAN BOOS,
ABSOLUTELY.
>> HIS PERSONALITY IS A LITTLE
BIT ON THE -- OVER THE TOP.
>> THERE'S A SPECIAL GUEST
COMING TONIGHT.
>> OH, YEAH, WE HEARD.
THE ONE THAT DOESN'T LIKE
BASEBALL.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> WE'RE HERE TO SEE THE
BASEBALL GAME.
>> DO YOU THINK HE'LL GET A WARM
WELCOME OR BOOED OR WHAT?
>> MIXED.
>> PROBABLY MIXED.
YEAH.
>> IS HE -- UP TO A FEW MONTHS
AGO HE WANTED PEOPLE TO BOYCOTT,
YES?
>> COULDN'T FIGURE THAT OUT.
YOU WILL NEVER SEE BASEBALL
BOYCOTTERS HERE.
>> SPECIAL GUEST COMING TONIGHT.
WHO IS THAT?
>> TRUMP?
I LOVE IT.
THAT'S MY MAN.
>> YOU THINK HE WILL GET A WARM
RECEPTION HERE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
ATLANTA FANS LOVE HIM.
HE SHOULD HAVE WON THE ELECTION.
>> Reporter: THE FORMER
PRESIDENT BACK IN STATE,
GEORGIA, HE FALSELY MAINTAINS
THAT HE DIDN'T LOSE IN THE
ELECTION 12 MONTHS AGO.
OF COURSE WE